the the Romney folks do whatever they're
told say they were told to stay home so
they stood they stayed home hi this is
zech why smaller for reason TV we're
outside of the republican national
convention floor where the chairman just
called the meeting into order and then
immediately resets 2012 republican
national convention stands in recess
subject to the call of the chair
interestingly a large number of the
delegates on the floor were not Romney
supporters but instead stood behind
congressman Ron Paul many of the RNC
delegates were told not to bother coming
out because of the inclement weather but
of course Ron Paul supporters cannot be
stopped by Hurricane Isaac are you a
Mitt Romney supporter um I will support
him on the ballot in November but I
personally think that Texas congressman
Ron Paul would make much more of a
better conservative constitutionalists
and somebody who could unite the vote so
about ten members of the main delegation
lost their seats earlier this week what
where are we with that what what do you
expect going forward well tomorrow when
we want to try to fight and make an
amendment to that motion that the main
delegation gets seated in full as they
were elected at the main state
convention that's the mains Alamo I mean
that's our last-ditch effort a
disproportionate amount of people have
been going up to today have told me that
they are Ron Paul supporters I'm
actually having trouble finding a Romany
supporter part of is I just think there
are more Ron Paul people here we came
here to come to the convention for and
initially we were told there was nothing
going to be happening today so a lot of
the buses that transport delegates from
the various hotels to the convention
were not running so that's why a lot of
the Romney people stayed where they were
for the most part the Ron Paul delegates
are here to actually work and so if
there's something that could be done
we're going to be here to do it and for
the most part the the Romney folks do
whatever they're told say they were told
to stay home and so they stood they
stayed home but you are bound to cast at
least your first ballot for Mitt Romney
correct according to the rules the RNC
hopefully they can come out and clarify
that but until then I think there's so
much vagueness in the rule
that as a lot of people have interpreted
it delegates are there to vote their
contents at this convention there's a
small chance that Ron Paul would
probably even get the required plurality
of five states or depending on how the
fight goes in the Rules Committee it
might be raised to an eight-state
majority to even speak these conventions
are not supposed to be coronations
they're supposed to be fights on the
floor let's look at this as a convention
and that the people have elected or duly
elected representative states to come
out and voice who the states represent
and once that can be when the convention
convenes and the roll calls are made
we'll find out if Mitt Romney has a
nomination enough do you still expect to
be able to put up a little fight we
expect to put up a little bit of a fight
whether we'll be successful eyes a whole
another question